en face à face étudiants gouvernement
tout le monde se déclarent prêts à
négocier mais ne se démobilise pas pour
autant le point des autonomistes dans
les élections pays basque espagnol avec
un enjeu l'attitude future les gardes de
l'hôte et l'olympique de marseille
survole le championnat de france de
football l'équipe de bernard tapie est
virtuellement championne d'automne
et puis ce samedi 29 novembre un jour de
détention supplémentaires pour les
otages français du liban
marcel fontaine marcel carton jean paul
kauffmann aurel cornéa et jean louis
normandin nos confrères d'antenne 2
n'ont toujours pas été libérés
madame monsieur bonsoir c'est un homme
qui revient de très très loin imaginez
plutôt quatre jours et quatre nuits
coincé dans sa voiture au fond d'un
fossé une banale partie de chasse qui
tourne très vite au cauchemar
le désespoir qui s'installe en même
temps que la fin et que la soif et puis
l'un de ses sourires du destin qui font
à nouveau record à la vie en
l'occurrence un paysan qui passait par
là
c'est une histoire que nous raconte
maintenant pascal deschamps et noël
alexandre quatre jours 4 nuits
prisonnier d'une carcasse de voiture
dans ce fossé à quelques mètres d'une
petite route de campagne
des dizaines de voitures qui passent et
phase une qui ne s'arrête pas un
automobiliste qui n'entendent décrit de
plus en plus faibles l'alertent a bien
été donnée mais les gendarmes ne sont
pas venus fouiller par ici et puis au
matin du quatrième jour un homme à pied
un charpentier dont le fourgon vient de
tomber en panne c'est peut-être simple
destin il entend des gémissements et
aperçoit enfin la voiture en contrebas
premier coup j'ai entendu aux co à l'est
de bombay sur le coup ça m'a un peu
suffoquée jeune homme alors dans la nuit
comme ça on sait jamais et puis ça
répondait aussitôt au secours allen le
deuxième coup dont c'est là que j'ai dit
comme c'est bizarre il ya quand même un
truc quoi c'est vrai il a donc j'ai
couru chez monsieur
gillot boullemant pour cogner ses volets
tout pourrait téléphoner aux gendarmes
aux propriétaires pour donner de l'aisne
assez normal il était temps après quatre
jours passés à lutter contre la soif et
la faim
lionel brousse où se demandait s'il
n'allait pas mourir à quelques mètres de
la civilisation
ça fait longtemps qu'ils ont été créés
tout ça mais je prends que la première
chose qui vient à l'esprit c'est mais
bon sang mais est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui pense à moi qui pense à venir me
chercher quoi ce qui devait terrible
surtout si longtemps ces voitures à
proximité se dire palu ne va s'arrêter
cet endroit là ah oui bien sûr et
d'ailleurs je peux même donné les
chiffres l'équipement il ya peu près 250
de 180 voitures qui passent par jour sur
sept mois
il vous faisait sentir n'est pas
vraiment jeté avec moi même ça avait
quoi que je dis pas que jeudi matin
quand j'ai vu le jour arriver le jour
n'était pas relevé un coin mais je me
suis dit que peut-être là ça commençait
à venir très très très dur
ce qu'elle va dire franchement la vérité
il faut qu'on arrête en panne qui tu
devrais peut-être tout et on chez pol
il a effectué un check mauvais stop
février
lionel rousseau c'était le nom de
l'automobiliste vous l'aviez compris les
étudiants plutôt réservé après le report
de la discussion sur le projet de loi
devaquet sur l'enseignement supérieur le
gouvernement se dit prêt au dialogue par
la voix de rené monory est le nouveau
calendrier des discussions sera connu au
début de la semaine en attendant la
grève se poursuivra dans les universités
le point tout de suite avec olivier
werner
d'une autorisation difficile de tenir
une assemblée générale dans une fac
aujourd'hui à part qui à jussieu par
exemple on entre eux plus aujourd'hui
les vigiles filtraient les entrées
mais lundi les étudiants ont bien
l'intention de réoccuper les amphis
entièrement en continu regardez bouche
notre notre objectif à nous c'est de ces
le retrait du projet de loi devaquet et
on veut pas en démordre
donc messieurs à la sorbonne cet après
midi les étudiants s'interroge faut-il
mettre en place des piquets de grève le
mouvement va-t-il se durcir et comment
réagir face au recul du gouvernement à
la place c'est vrai c'est pas une
victoire c'est une fausse victoire ce
qu'ils veulent c'est que ces souffles
l'égard de la semaine prochaine ont ce
qu'on arrête on reprennent les cours et
qu'après on pisse plus remobilisé
avertissement sévère ce matin de l'unef
id à travers un bref communiqué s'il
s'agit de gagner du temps le
gouvernement prendrait l'immense
responsabilité du durcissement de la
grille les étudiants demandent à être
reçus par les ministres de bach et
aumônerie d'ailleurs dès hier soir dans
les couloirs de l'assemblée rené monory
se disait prêt à négocier
je pars du principe en politique quand
un texte écrit et qui prête à d'autres
interprétations que son but
pas fou discuter puis s'il faut écrire
quelque chose dans le froid rien n'est
précis pour l'instant dont les modalités
et le calendrier du réexamen du projet
silence du gouvernement aujourd'hui
l'assemblée elle-même ne se décidera que
mardi prochain
il est vrai qu'il n'y a pas moins de
1400 amendements qui ont été déposés
cela mérite un grand dialogue
il reprend avec les jeunes qu'il reprend
avec le parlement il n'y a pas d'urgence
il faut donc faire les choses avec
beaucoup de sérénité
vous même vous dites qu'il n'ya pas
d'urgence donc ça peut être qu'un jour
ça fait trois semaines ça peut être même
plus long non ce mais laissons le
parlement jouer son rôle laissons le
gouvernement dialoguer et puis nous
ferons la synthèse de ces deux démarches
en tous les cas dès ce matin le dossier
universitaire a bien fait l'objet d'une
réunion des principaux ministres autour
de jacques chirac
mais il faudra attendre la fin du
week-end pour connaître les vraies
solutions apportées par le gouvernement
le rebondissement brésilien de la sphère
chalier le jornal do brasil un des
grands quotidiens brésiliens affirme que
l'accusé numéro 1 dans la sphère du
carrefour du développement aurait reçu
son faux passeport des mains d'un ancien
secrétaire d'état à la police de l'état
de rio
le même journal indique que kitsch à
lloret est hébergée à rioz justement par
l'un des responsables de la mafia des
machinations dans la sphère des ventes
d'armes américaines à l'iran chaque jour
apporte aussi son lot de révélations
dernière en date celle du times de
londres qui affirme que vingt avions
cargos ont livré des armes américaines à
téhéran alors que robert mcfarlane le
conseiller de ronald reagan se
trouvaient en iran c'était tout
printemps dernier si cette information
est recoupée cela ne pourra manquer
d'embarrasser à nouveau le président
américain qui se retrouve aujourd'hui le
dos au mur avec de nouvelles démissions
ou de nouveau limogeage qui se profile à
l'horizon de la maison blanche
des précisions à washington avec jacques
à bouchon
une vingtaine d'avions cargo aurait donc
livré à terre de l'équipement militaire
américain principalement des armes et
des moteurs de chars pendant la visite
secrète en iran de robert mcfarlane au
printemps dernier on est loin des
estimations de ronald reagan qui dans sa
dernière conférence de presse avait
parlé d' envoi en quantité limitée
représente en un seul chargement
le président n'aura pas trop ces quatre
jours de vacances qu'il s'est accordé
dans son range de californie pour mettre
au point une stratégie efficace face à
un congrès hostile et à une presse
déchaînée
ronald reagan secrétaire général de la
maison blanche et à son tour très menacé
accusé d'avoir supervisé l'opération
iranienne il a démenti sans convaincre
william casey le patron de la cia est
lui aussi sous le feu
il va devoir s'expliquer devant les
différentes commissions saisies du
dossier au sénat et à la chambre des
représentants car personne et washington
ne semble accorder le moindre crédit à
la thèse officielle de la maison blanche
selon laquelle le colonel north était
seul au courant de toute la sphère le
président a donné carte blanche au
ministre de la justice
edwin mise pour faire toute la lumière
sur le scandale méfiant le congrès exige
de mener sa propre enquête
car estime-t-il le ministre ami
personnel de ronald reagan risque d'être
juge et partie
le congrès ne fera aucun cadeau il faut
pas oublier que depuis les élections du
4 novembre il est entièrement dominée au
sénat comme à la chambre des
représentants par l'opposition démocrate
pour un bombardier de trop s'en est fini
formellement du moins de l'accord salt 2
sur les armements stratégiques
la mise en service de ce 131e b52 au
texas risque fort d'ailleurs de sonner
le glas des négociations sur le
désarmement
la raison en est simple moscou et
washington s'étaient entendus sur un
seuil de missiles 1320 pour chacun des
deux pays
le seuil est dépassé aujourd'hui par
l'amérique puisque ce nouveau bombardier
transportera 12 missiles qui viennent en
surnombre un déséquilibre qui n'est pas
vraiment significatif mais qui pourrait
compter dans une nouvelle négociation
qui ne manquent on fera bien sûr dessous
j'ai donc fait 52e 61e qui pose problème
maintenant sur ces négociations
près de deux mille arrestations 70 mille
policiers qui bloquaient les grandes
avenues de séoul en corée une ville en
état de siège
la manifestation de l'opposition au
régime sud coréen s'est terminée dans la
violence comme on pouvait le redouter
du coup les responsables des partis
d'opposition ont préféré tout simplement
annulé leur mouvement patricia cost
les députés de l'opposition en corée du
sud
on le sent vif regardez plutôt ils vont
s'attaquer à mains nues à la police
les policiers sont plus nombreux ils
étaient soixante dix mille soixante dix
mille hommes ce matin pour réprimer une
manifestation interdite
les députés à la dernière minute ont
annulé leur mot d'ordre
trop tard les étudiants ont pris le
relais de plus en plus actifs il avait
préparé tout un lot de cocktails molotov
845 exactement selon le chef de la
police qui en a fait le décompte
deuxième charge les manifestants seront
dispersées en une heure mais ces
troubles limités aujourd'hui intervienne
dans un pays qui vit sur un volcan en
rouge sur la carte située entre les deux
géants aux communistes la chine et
l'urss
la corée du sud est continuellement sous
tension sous ses yeux
l'attrait stalinienne corée du nord de
kim il sung et à l'intérieur même de son
territoire une opposition en ébullition
les députés demandent est aujourd'hui
davantage de démocratie
il y a eu en corée du sud des élections
parlementaires mais non présidentielle
une ouverture s'était esquissée il ya
quelques mois
remise en cause aujourd'hui le pays
basque espagnol à la veille d'élections
législatives un scrutin anticipé après
l'éclatement du principal parti basque
le pnv des élections néanmoins sorte
importante demain dans toute la province
puisqu'elles ont pour enjeu la violence
qui bouleverse le pays basque espagnol
on sort en effet quelle est l'importance
réelle des mouvements autonomistes qui
représente qui présente des candidats et
surtout on aura une meilleure idée de
l'attitude des basques à l'égard de
l'hôte et bruno le dreff philippe
etcheverry doha et amylie tara vive le
thé à militaires crie-t-il les candidats
déry batasuna le plus extrémiste des
partis nationalistes basques sont bien
ceux de la branche politique de l' eta
depuis dix ans ce parti gagne des voix
chaque élection il approche maintenant
les 20 % ses sympathisants à clame ce
que le gouvernement espagnol fred de
terroristes ceux qui depuis 1976 ont tué
près de 600 personnes
en espagne les meetings des ribette
hassoun a rassemblé foules les plus
impressionnantes de cette campagne
ces élus ont toujours refusé de siéger
au parlement autonome basse lundi ils
viendront pour la première fois
s'asseoir ici participer au gouvernement
des trois provinces basques
et dire qu'il faut négocier avec le dea
au contraire du principal parti
nationaliste basque le pnv pour espérer
qu'on a un surplus nouvelle et plus
équilibrée de dison des des attentats ou
des actions violentes et ça n'a pas été
le cas
les partis nationalistes basques
dernièrement mais fin des combats mais
toujours les actions des patriotes au
classement le parti nationaliste basque
avec 40% des voix représente une énorme
machine sociopolitique 173 meurtres est
100 conseillers municipaux
ils contrôlent la majeure partie de la
vie politique de la région et refuse
toute négociation avec le t1 mais une
large frange du parti a fait scission
sous l'affluence de cet homme l'un de
ses anciens dirigeants carlos garetto
richie a il jugeait le pnv trop mou à
l'égard du gouvernement central de
madrid
paradoxalement à cause de cette scission
le parti socialiste de felipe gonzalez
au pouvoir à madrid pourrait bien
remporter les élections
un cadeau empoisonné c'est le parti
socialiste sol qui devrait alors tenté
de régler les deux grands problèmes qui
frappent le pays basque le chômage et
surtout le terrorisme
en marge du débat politique proprement
dit au pays basque espagnol un nouvel
attentat ce matin contre un
concessionnaire peugeot de san sébastian
n'y a pas de victime mais c'est la
quatrième fois que ce processionnaires
fait ainsi l'objet d'un attentes alors
que le froid est à nos portes le fuel
joue à la baisse c'est une conséquence
de la libération des prix et de la
concurrence acharnée que se livrent
maintenant les distributeurs qui sont en
quelque sorte en mal de clients bataille
sur les prix bataille sur les délais de
paiement tous les arguments sont bons
résultats les consommateurs devraient
peut-être y trouver leur compte
en quête de geneviève moll
ces péniches sont à la fête elles y vont
à nouveau du fioul le marché repart
alors que depuis quelques années le
fioul était en perte de vitesse à cause
de l'envolée des prix du pétrole et de
la concurrence acharnée que lui livrer
le gaz et l'électricité
aujourd'hui le prix du fioul a baissé
mais les distributeurs ont aussi fait
des efforts pour fidéliser leur
clientèle
premier système mis en place la gestion
des livraisons et le paiement par
mensualités je ne m'occupe d'eux
pratiquement d'orient je reçois tous les
ans un contrat de une proposition de
contrat de prélèvement et
sous cette forme on pratique à la mesure
je pêche l'année mais paiement et je
peux
organisez monde j'ai ma convenance c'est
une facilité mais le client dans ce cas
p4 et demi pour cent d'intérêt
cette dépense supplémentaire est
cependant compensé par les quantités
livrées par le distributeur pour le
client il bénéficie compte tenu que la
livraison et plus massive d'un prix plus
avantageux c'est ça ça veut dire que au
lieu de prendre mille litres par exemple
il va prendre milly de 3000 litres d'un
coup absolument absolument et c'est par
ce grâce à cela il a pu bénéficier d'un
prix qui est nettement plus intéressant
autre système
la carte aurore mise en place chez les
distributeurs bp il s'agit d'une carte
de crédit qui peut servir à n'importe
quel achat aujourd'hui elle permet aussi
d'acheter son fuel
mais si les agios là sont de 17,6 pour
cent
elle fait jouer à plein la concurrence
alors comment arrivez-vous à illies
d'argent finalement eh bien je tends ma
chère c'est à dire en faisant jouer nos
fournisseurs
la concurrence aussi les prix du fioul
varient d'un distributeur à l'autre de
10 à 20 francs par hectolitre pas
négligeable pour le consommateur ça
c'est pour les particuliers mais pour le
chauffage collectif on n'en est pas là
et si les charges fioul sont restés
stables l'année dernière elles risquent
d'augmenter selon les gardiens
d'immeuble avec la suppression des
dégrèvements pour économies d'énergie de
quoi envier ceux qui possèdent encore
les bonnes vieilles cheminées des
familles
l'olympique de marseille très probable
champion d'automne après la raclée
infligée hier soir au paris saint
germain 4 buts à 0
une seule inconnue maintenant le
résultat du match saint-etienne bordeaux
qui se joue tout à l'heure ce soir donc
à saint-etienne mais il faudrait quand
même que bordeaux fasse un véritable
carton pour damer le pion au club
marseillais l'om superstar ce qui fait
bien les affaires de son patron bernard
tapie commentaires dominique loof 40000
supporters keith howlett en cascade
voici la vague de fond de l'olympique de
marseille qui submerge le football
français victimes d'hier soir le
champion de france en titre le paris
saint-germain balayée 4 buts à 0 au
stade vélodrome une excuse cependant
pour le psg la blessure de joël bats
irréprochable en début de partie sur un
coup franc de
louis zanon mais victime par la suite
d'un choc est rien bilan une côte
fracturée une nuit d'hôpital et surtout
une sortie à la mi-temps qui vont
handicaper les parisiens des parisiens
certes déjà menés 2-0 à la mi-temps
premier but de la tête par l'oreille et
un second toujours de la tête mais celle
de cubaine cette fois une relance à la
main de belle and intelligent
débordement de jean pierre papin qui a
bien vu au second poteau patrick
cubaynes démarquer
marseille s'enflamme vocifère et
s'extasient devant ses nouveaux minots
et quand cubaine file vers le but janot
le gardien d'un fortune se demande bien
ce qu'il fait dans cette galère fluctuat
nec mergitur le bateau parisien coule
coule définitivement même sur un nouveau
coup de bélier de jean pierre papin
malgré une sortie désespérée de janot
qui réussit à toucher le ballon avec la
main mais insuffisamment pour le
détourner du chemin des boues marseille
sourient
elle a retrouvé son football et ses
émotions bravo banide et bravo les
joueurs parce que c'est un taux est
heureusement un club c'est une famille
c'est un clan c'est une tribu et c'est
un petit peu ce qu'on a essayé de faire
à l'om mais avant tout c'est et
entreprises alors l'olympique de
marseille un modèle pour l'avenir
en tous les cas pour le présent une
entreprise qui sait vendre produire un
spectacle et obtenir des résultats
pourvu que ça dure
juste à cela vous le savez peut-être que
joël bats été blessés hier lors du match
contre marseille et bien battre je
l'apprends sera indisponible jusqu'à la
trêve hivernale en ski l'ouverture de la
21e coupe du monde avec le slalom de
sestrières c'est en italie et une
nouvelle victoire pour une gamme arsène
marque que vous voyez il devance de deux
centièmes son compatriote suédois jonas
nilsson dans un style très cool et sans
donner l'impression de forcer
cette marque remporté à 681 quatrième
succès à 31 ans est bien une mars au
danemark est toujours la référence
aujourd'hui dans le ski mondiaux george
benson en tournée à paris en province
c'est un événement pour ce chanteur
américain qui a choisi de ne chanter ni
la drogue ni l'assiette ni le sexe ni la
violence
l'idole bien lisse d'une certaine
musique américaine qui fait quand même
courir les foules ou alors george benson
est il un chanteur décalé jean jacques
dufour et didier rancoeurs sont allés
lui rendre visite en grande bretagne où
il se produisait avant donc d'arriver
demain à paris
voici leurs repas vous vous demandez ce
qui les a mis dans cet état
réponse les mélodies de george benson
nous sommes à birmingham où il se
produisait juste avant son passage à
paris
tandis que sur scène
georges la quarantaine velouté et l'oeil
pétillant d'humour répéter en coulisses
on préparait les batteries de cuisine
les tournées ça creuse qu'est ce que
vous pensez de george benson tu veux le
savoir je le trouve très sexy opaque
pour soigner son image sexy benson
préfère le noir
premièrement parce que cette couleur le
rend plus mince et deuxièmement lance
exporte quelque chose de très sombre
alors son visage par les plus claires en
résumé cela fait ressentir ces prêts à
propos de variété il estime qu'il y a
trop de sexe trop de drogues dans les
chansons
lui qui préfère parler d'amour alors
avis aux amateurs à paris demain soir à
lyon le 7 et à toulouse le 8
benson viendra donner un petit coup de
chaud à nos nuits que la froidure
commence à emprisonner les tiercés de
fin de semaine maintenant avec celui qui
se courait d'abord donc aujourd'hui à
saint-cloud combinaison gagnante 4 à ses
huit rapports dans l'heure pour 500 4493
fonds et 50 centimes et rapport pour 500
déplacés dans un ordre différent 745
francs tout roule
avant de parler du tiercé de demain
pierrette brès hameau de la grande
nouveauté qui se prépare à qu'on appelle
déjà le car c'est plus alors c'est pour
bientôt d'abord vous savez après l'échec
du derby fallait compenser un petit peu
alors on a créé ce quarté + et ce quarté
+ et bien c'est un jeu beaucoup plus
simple qui logiquement devraient
commencer au mois de juin 1987 le
dimanche à hollywood mais c'est ça ce
sera le dimanche à grigny avec après le
lapin du quercy avec vous immédiatement
en images comment ça va se passer
comment va fonctionner ce nouveau jeu
absolument le pmu de l'an 2000 est en
marche avant 1988
tous les bureaux du pari mutuel urbain
seront informatisées ce qui permettra
non seulement de mieux utiliser la gamme
actuelle des jeux offerts aux turfiste
mais de créer aussi d'autres modes de
paris
à condition bien sûr que la clientèle
suivent et pour que la clientèle suivent
eh bien il faut relancer l'intérêt des
parieurs surtout ceux qui n'ont pas de
chance c'était simple mais il fallait y
penser et c'est maintenant chose faite
avec le nouveau quartier plus et qu'est
ce que c'est que ce quarté + c'est en
fait un carton avec un trio de
consolation ça c'est pour les curistes
pour les noms turfiste c'est un jeu qui
consiste à désigner quatre chevaux avec
un ordre spécifié vous gagnez le rapport
le plus élevé si vous avez trouvé les
quatre premiers de la course dans
l'ordre un rapport moins élevé si vous
les avez trouvés mais pas dans le bon
ordre d'arrivée et vous êtes consoler si
vous n'avez trouvé que les trois
premiers
et ça précisément c'était une attente
des parieurs quarté + permettra de
satisfaire un plus grand nombre de
turfiste mais en revanche pour le touche
dans l'ordre dans le désordre les
rapports en seront considérablement
diminué d'après les statistiques
à titre d'exemple pour une mise de
seafrance si vous gagnez avec quatre
chevaux dans l'ordre vous toucherez 15 %
de la masse répartie soit environ vingt
mille 700 francs si vos quatre chevaux
arrivent dans le désordre
vous toucherez 35% de la répartition des
masses soit 1890 francs et si vous
n'avez trouvé que trois chevaux
quel que soit l'ordre ils vous
rapporteront 150 francs puisque 50% vous
seront attribués les rapports du quarté
+ seront trois fois moins élevé que dans
le quartier traditionnel
dans un sens on privilégie les perdants
mais dans l'autre on risque de
décourager ceux qui gagnent vous la
question est-ce que c'est beto est ce
que ça commence faire et comme prévu en
principe oui mais ça fait pas
l'unanimité on n'est pas d'accord
surtout dans la presse hippique bon on
verra ça plus tard le tir 7 2 bat
maintenant tu as passé ta auteuil et je
pourrais vous dire qu à auteuil et bien
les héros sont un peu fatigués parce que
depuis début da saison il ya eu beaucoup
de chutes donc il faut un petit peu
laisse tranquille et ça manque un petit
peu de partants auteuil alors les plus
belles courses de la réunion ne peuvent
pas servir de support aux paris car
c'est parce qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment
de choix engagés
non c'est pas ça mais on a été obligé de
sacrifier la qualité à la quantité
et on a choisi une course plus modestes
un steeple-chase qui s'appelle le prix
bernard dufau c'est une course de
steeple-chase de 4100 mètres qui
s'adresse plus particulièrement aux
chevaux âgés de 5 ans et plus et ils
seront dix huit à s'affronter dans cette
épreuve à laon heureusement ils doivent
quand même un favori et vaut mieux jouer
ce prudent vie aux jouets valeurs sûres
et ce favori c'est nord assez entraîné
par françois doumen et dans le pronostic
que je propose de jouer maintenant et
bien bien évidemment il sera la base de
mon jeu alors en tête tout de suite de
ce prolifique nord assez qui va porter
le numéro deux il sera suivi de
richelieu drôle numéro 7 montre hsf le 5
pas landes
le sis au chi chi le numéro 10 chez rose
numéro 8
ensuite numéro 3 diaz hausse est le
numéro 1 décisif
notez bien là
2 7 5 6 10 8 3 years l'avant dernier
volet de notre série consacrée à la
photo en marge du mois de la photo
justement qui se termine à paris tout au
long de la semaine christian roux nous a
emmenés à la découverte de photos et de
photographes pas tout à fait comme les
autres ce soir il nous présente la
double vie de patrick lazartigues
au soir
je me permets de vous faire voir ces
quelques photos que j'ai réalisé par des
pressions de toutes les personnalités
qui passe à la coupole
voila voila je vous laisse regarder si
vous voulez bien
je change de métier
l'espace de dix minutes je ne suis plus
garçon de restaurant du tout je suis
photographe à part entière il y a des
fois je me rappelle il ya quelques temps
il m'est arrivé dans la soirée deux
changé six fois de métier parce que par
la présence de six personnalités
différentes
oui tout à fait tout est fait à la
coupole par le club photo ma peau pâle
sous les toits de la coupole une heure
après les mains après un club photo et
on fait ça sous les poids d'après midi
pour occuper
les coupures
faites vous le sauriez la souris
oui vous et bernard cyr hockey à temps
voilà fois ce coup de rouge la météo ce
sera un projet simonetta plus clair ce
soir et on prend le même soleil on
recommence c'est exactement ça nous
sommes empêtrés dans un anticyclone
alors on peut s'en réjouir parce qu'ils
nous apportent une grande stabilité
on peut aussi sont attristés par ce
qu'ils canalisent un air froid donc
soleil froid auquel il faut apporter
tout de même quelques nuances regardons
la photo satellite et vous allez
remarquer que des brouillards
aujourd'hui certains brouillard ne se
sont pratiquement pas dissipées ce qui l
est de la bretagne au centre et à la
bourgogne
et puis on fait il ya une dépression qui
est située sur la méditerranée les vents
soufflent dans le sens inverse des
aiguilles d'une montre
il ramène ses nuages sur les côtes de
france résultat sur la carte de demain
du brouillard de la brume le matin long
à se dissiper important surtout sur le
nord-est le centre et le sud ouest ainsi
que la bretagne nord ouest lorsqu'ils se
seront dissipées ce sera du beau temps
mais toujours une grande instabilité sur
le flanc sud c'est à dire une alternance
d'éclaircies et de nuages qui donneront
des averses et ses nuages gagneront en
milieu d'après-midi les pyrénées
centrales
alors qu'une amélioration se produira
sur la côte d'azur et la corse
température pour cette nuit jusqu'à -2
degrés au nord ouest - cattrall est
moins 5 sur le massif central et puis
les températures maximales celle que
vous aurez demain dans l'après midi aux
environs de 15 heures elles seront en
légère baisse aussi de 4 à 8 degrés sur
la moitié nord 5 à orgeval et de 5 à 14
degrés sur la moitié sud mais 14
seulement à nice et sur la corse
demain ce sera le dimanche 39 ans une
minute de soleil en moins
il se lèvera 8h22 se couchera 16h56 et
ce sera la faire rentrer les bonnes
feuilles pour les anglais ce dernier
journal ce sera avec philippe harrouard
juste après les enfants du rock c'est à
dire aux environs de minuit un peu plus
simplement on sait pas encore bien car
il ya un grand direct avec michel druker
juste avant et puis demain pas télématin
puisque nous sommes samedi mais en
revanche premier rendez vos qualités
c'est 13 heures ce sera noël mamère
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain à
20h et d'ici là je vous souhaite une
très bonne soirée en notre compagnie
nature
qui quand index